I miss you guys BTS was our first of all
yeah I practiced that just for you hello
I practice - BTS is back their last
album love yourself her became the
highest charting album by a kpop act and
this next record
love yourself tear maybe their most
personal yet the fans wanna know about
the story guys what can you tell about
it you explain the storyline it's gonna
be long if I like span and law but this
time and this time this album is gonna
be like if you're not shoot yourself
like your love will finally it won't
last
so like you'll see in the choreography
I'm like in the lyrics so you'll see
laughter what was the inspiration behind
this next era BTS this time it's about
like the satin is and like tear and like
honesty and love because you know
sometimes we just turn away from the
summons sort of situations because you
know like in love and life like we it's
not like a fairy tale right we always
have the like a dark sides so we want to
talk about like the dark sides of that
the name of the new record is love
yourself tear was it has there ever been
a time where you guys did it love
yourself and how did you overcome that
actually my final goal of the whole my
whole life is to love myself like for
real cuz you know it's always the
hardest
we sometimes compare ourselves to others
and you know like sometimes get really
depressed or you know so but in love
like we should be we should be you know
take off the mask and be true to ours
who we are the best way to love yourself
and reality is like to throw ourselves
like you know to watch ourselves like
growing
it's like the best way to lower self
well one thing's for sure BTS is
surrounded by love who has been the
biggest influence or motivation in your
lives my my father and mother sister mmm
your family my member BTS that's right
oh yeah yeah yeah and my puppy
Ricky and our fast army and army
[Music]